hi this is cynthia thomas i'm a
networking specialist
at google cloud welcome back to what's
new in networking
today we're going to talk about anthos
and compute networking launches
so stay tuned
[Music]
let's start with kubernetes as more
enterprises adopt kubernetes
new requirements are coming up around
multi-cloud
security and visibility and new
technologies like service mesh
demand more customizations of the
underlying kubernetes layer
these requirements all need a more
programmable data plane
that can do kubernetes aware networking
without sacrificing
performance i'm pleased to introduce to
you data plane v2
data plane v2 is an opinionated data
plane
for gke and anthos clusters
and it's been optimized for kubernetes
networking
dataplan v2 is implemented with ebpf
extended berkeley packet filter this
handles network packets in the kernel by
configuring the data plane
using kubernetes specific metadata
data plane b2 brings several advantages
to your deployments
from a security and operations
perspective
you have native kubernetes network
policy
and logging without the need for a third
party
add-on network policy logging
lets you monitor how your policies are
enforcing traffic
that way you can see allowed and denied
network connections
in the cloud logging console to audit
and troubleshoot policies data plane v2
also lends well to large environments
for scale
without the need for a cube proxy nor ip
tables
for service routing finally
the big thing data plane v2 brings to
your multi-faceted environments
is consistency across environment types
gke anthoc vsphere and anthocon bare
metal
with data plane v2 you can quickly
identify
abnormal traffic patterns and spot
irregular
network activity finally let's talk
about
google virtual nick or gvnec for short
it's a virtual network interface
designed specifically
for google compute engine
previously vms that ran on compute
engine
used a virtual network interface based
on the vert
i o spec for better networking
performance
and to support additional features
google uses gvnic
as its default virtual network interface
gvenic supports higher network
bandwidths such as 50 to 100 gigabits a
second
these can be used for distributed
workloads on vms
that have attached gpus if you want to
use
gbnix you can use it on a supported os
or on an unsupported os by manually
installing the drivers
for linux or windows and that's our
update for anthos and compute networking
check out the links below for more
details on these new features
join us next time for what's new in
[Music]
networking
you